-She stars
in the new movie "Jolt,"
available on
Prime Video tomorrow.
Please welcome the one and only
Kate Beckinsale!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, come on.
Mwah! Mwah!
Kate Beckinsale!
Welcome.
Welcome back to the show.
Thank you for being here.
And now we're going to face off
in a game called "Box of Lies."
-♪ Box of Lies, Box of Lies,
Box of Lies, Box of Lies ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
and take out the object
and describe it
to your opponent.
And then, they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
I'm not gonna
look at you because...
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna play three rounds.
Kate, you pick the first box.
-Okay.
Any suggestions at all?
[ Audience shouting ]
All right, five it is, then.
I have not
played this game before.
Okay.
-All right.
-What do I do now?
-Now you open the box
and then put it off
to the side on this side.
Yeah, and I won't
look or listen.
I'll make noise.
Quest, can you
give us some drums?
I don't want to hear anything.
♪♪
All right, perfect.
[ Light laughter ]
-Well, what if
I don't know what it is?
[ Laughter ]
-This could be part
of the lie or the truth.
-I can smell it,
but I don't know what it is.
-Okay. So it has a scent.
That's a hint.
-Can I move over and smell it?
-Yeah, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Am I allowed to deconstruct it?
I genuinely
don't know what this is.
[ Laughter ]
It might be an English thing
but I've never -- what is that?
Oh! I know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
-I'm sucking at this already.
-No.
-Okay.
It's a small
floral arrangement...
-Yeah.
-...containing some corn dogs.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Small floral arrangement
of corn dogs.
That sounds actually
pretty good to me.
That's very -- it's American.
Corn dogs.
I can't smell them from here.
I feel like
I would smell a hot dog.
-I mean, it could be a bluff.
You know what I mean?
But maybe it doesn't --
-But it's not Box of Bluffs.
It's not Box of Bluffs.
-It's Box of Lies.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, wait.
Small floral arrangement
of corn dogs.
Kate Beckinsale,
would you lie to me?
I will say that it is a...
I think it's the truth.
-I think it is, but I've never
touched a corn dog before.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
All right, now,
hold on a second.
Oh!
-Yes!
I win!
-Is that what it is?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-So I got it.
You're smelling --
I see now, I get it, yes.
So, I got that one.
You could put that away.
-Smelled like a doughnut, so
I was thrown off for a second.
-That's definitely a corn dog.
Oh, yeah.
-Okay, good.
-All right.
Which one should I pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
I fee like --
Kate, you can put that there
now, if you want to.
Someone was very adamant on 6.
-No!
-"No." Why?
[ Laughter ]
"No!"
[ Grunting ]
-So it's a light object.
[ Laughter ]
-This is my acting.
[ Humming "Baby Elephant Walk" ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Okay.
It's interesting.
-Okay. What you got?
-Well, it's another thing
that you could smell, as well.
I can smell it already.
Um...
-You're cooking up a lie!
You're cooking up a lie!
I can see
you're cooking up a lie.
-You can tell already?
-I feel like you're wanting to.
-It's a
Nintendo Entertainment System
with a cartridge that's made out
of a grilled-cheese sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
It's not funny.
It's not time
to laugh at everything.
Sometimes things are serious
in life.
-I bet this is an item that
you would have in your house.
Like, you've come up with that
because you've seen that.
-In my house? You think
I would have that in my house?
-Yeah.
-A Nintendo Entertainment --
with a grilled cheese with it?
-That seems so on brand for you.
[ Laughter ]
-It is on brand.
Am I telling the truth
or telling a lie?
♪♪
-You're telling a lie.
-I'm telling the truth.
-No!
Oh, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah, thank you!
You guys are good!
The audience helped me out.
You guys are good.
They kind of
helped me with that.
I love that, yeah.
I don't know if I --
It's tough to lie to you.
You know, I'm a big fan of you.
All right, guys.
Which one?
[ Audience shouting ]
I'm hearing 2.
-No!
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
In my box
was something very sweet.
It is...
[ Laughter ]
...little dolls...
with Olympic medals...
made out of Frosted Mini Wheats.
Which may be American product.
-Is it specifically a wheat?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean,
I could try it after this.
I don't have an allergy,
but I do know
a Frosted Mini Wheat
when I see it.
-You do?
I of course don't.
-Yes.
Weetabix.
-Oh, got it.
Okay.
-But an American version
and frosted on one side.
-Fancy.
And then, you say...
gold medals, you say?
-No, all three.
Representing all three.
-Oh, really?
-First, second, and third.
-Okay.
And do they have different
facial expressions
or all the same?
-They're barely faces.
They're just...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, okay.
-They look like
they should be something,
but they're made out of wheat.
[ Laughter ]
Little squares of wheat.
-Oh, the dolls
are made of wheat.
-Squares of wheat.
Yes.
-Wearing medals.
-Little tiny medals.
-In a receptacle of any kind?
-They're on a podium.
-A podium?
-An Olympic podium.
[ Laughter ]
-They're not.
You're lying.
-What?
-I think you're lying.
I don't think there's
such a thing in the world
as a Mini Wheat doll,
let alone --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You are correct!
[ Ding! ]
Oh, my God!
You are so good!
-That's me!
♪♪
-Do you now know Mini Wheats?
-I don't.
I'm not great at American
breakfast cereal.
-Oh, my gosh.
Next time you come on,
we have to get you
Frosted Mini Wheats.
We have to try American cereal.
-There could be no going back.
-No, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna give the win
to Kate Beckinsale.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
The greatest.